Willkommen zurück bei Quantum Computing in der Praxis. Ich bin eure Gastgeberin Olivia Lanes. Letztes Mal haben wir ein Beispiel für einen
Quantum-Computing-Ansatz für ein Optimierungsproblem durchgearbeitet, bekannt als Max-Cut, unter Verwendung der Qubo-Formulierung. Wir sind
ziemlich tief in die Materie eingetaucht, aber das war nur ein Beispiel für einen Ansatz. Heute werden wir Kurzzeit-Anwendungen
allgemeiner besprechen und unser Gespür für verschiedene Arten von Problemen entwickeln, bei denen wir nützliche Quantum-Lösungen
erwarten, und einige aktuelle Beispiele wichtiger Arbeiten aus unserer Community auf Utility-
Ebene ansehen. Zuvor haben wir kurz erwähnt, dass nicht alle Probleme zusätzliche Rechenleistung benötigen,
speziell Quantum Computing, um effizient gelöst zu werden. Das sind die Probleme, die euch bereits am besten
bekannt sind: Rechnen, Social Media scrollen, vielleicht Tetris, Doom oder andere Videospiele spielen. Wir bezeichnen diese allgemein als
einfache Probleme. Andererseits gibt es sehr schwierige Probleme, wie das Finden von Primfaktoren enormer
ganzer Zahlen – das ist die Grundlage der RSA-Verschlüsselung und wofür Shors Algorithmus ursprünglich entwickelt wurde. Ein weiteres
Beispiel ist das Finden einer Lösung in einem unsortierten Datensatz. Das kann theoretisch durch den Quantenalgorithmus
namens Grovers Algorithmus gelöst werden. Die meisten Experten sind sich jedoch einig, dass diese Arten von Algorithmen
Fehlerkorrektur erfordern werden, und technologisch sind wir noch nicht so weit. Wenn wir also in dieser
Lektion und auf eurem Quantum-Bildungsweg voranschreiten, denkt daran: Wir suchen diesen Sweet Spot irgendwo hier in der Mitte.
Es ist ein schwieriges Problem, aber genau das macht es auch so spannend. Eines, worüber wir noch nicht viel gesprochen haben,
ist die Theorie der Berechnungskomplexität. Einer der Gründe dafür ist, dass sie etwas einschüchternd wirken kann – und ja,
komplex. Die Berechnungskomplexitätstheorie ist das Teilgebiet der Informatik, das darauf abzielt, Berechnungsprobleme
nach ihrer Schwierigkeit zu klassifizieren. Es gibt eine Menge verschiedener Komplexitätsklassen im klassischen Computing, aber die grundlegendsten
sind diese P-Probleme. Das sind Probleme, die in polynomieller Zeit gelöst werden können und mit der
Problemgröße skalieren, was bedeutet, dass sie leicht zu lösen sind. Die nächste, schwierigere Art von Problemen sind NP-Probleme,
was für nicht-deterministisch polynomiell steht. Das sind Probleme, deren Antworten in polynomieller Zeit verifiziert, aber nicht
unbedingt gelöst werden können. Als nächstes kommt NP-vollständig, und jetzt kommen wir zu den wirklich herausfordernden Problemen ohne
bekannte polynomielle Lösung. Hier leben berühmte Probleme wie das Travelling-Salesman-Problem und sogar das Spiel
Sudoku. Als Quantum Computing – zumindest in der Theorie – aufkam, investierten Menschen erheblichen Aufwand, um herauszufinden,
welche Klasse von Problemen diese neuen Computertypen effizient lösen könnten. Eine neue Klasse von
Problemen wurde erfunden, genannt Bounded-Error Quantum Polynomial oder kurz BQP. Ihre genaue Definition ist etwas
länger, aber es ist die Klasse der Entscheidungsprobleme, die von einem Quantencomputer in polynomieller Zeit mit einer kleinen
Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit gelöst werden können. Es gibt eine Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit, weil Quantenmessung von Natur aus zufällig ist, aber die Fehler-
wahrscheinlichkeit kann beliebig klein gemacht werden. All diese Klassen leben nun in einer größeren Klasse, die wir PSPACE nennen, und hier
vermuten wir, dass BQP relativ zu all den anderen Problemtypen liegt – aber es ist sehr schwer, das definitiv zu beweisen,
mathematisch gesehen. Ihr werdet bemerken, dass BQP-Quantum-Probleme sich nicht unbedingt mit NP-vollständigen Problemen überschneiden.
Dennoch habt ihr vielleicht Quantum-Computing-Ansätze gesehen, die darauf abzielen, NP-vollständige Probleme zu lösen. Warum sollte
das so sein? Ein verbreitetes Missverständnis ist, dass es keinen Sinn macht, Lösungen
für Probleme wie das Travelling-Salesman-Problem und andere NP-vollständige Probleme für einen Quantencomputer zu erforschen, oder für jedes Problem, bei dem
kein mathematischer Beweis für eine Quantum-Beschleunigung gefunden wurde. Das muss jedoch nicht unbedingt der Fall sein.
Einen mathematischen Beweis dafür zu finden, dass ein Quantenalgorithmus schneller ist als sein klassisches Gegenstück, ist selten. Shor und
Grover sind zwei der wenigen Beispiele, bei denen das bisher gelungen ist. Aber das ist in Ordnung. In der Tat konnten Informatiker
noch nicht einmal beweisen, dass die Klassen P und NP verschieden sind, obwohl alle Intuition
uns sagt, dass sie es sein müssen. Außerdem vergleicht man zwei Algorithmen und wie sie skalieren, oft anhand des Worst-Case-
Szenarios für jeden. Es ist durchaus möglich, dass in der Praxis das Worst-Case-Szenario nicht das ist, was wir im echten Leben finden. Also
verzweifeln wir nicht, sondern führen stattdessen die Idee heuristischer Lösungen ein. Wenn du
Experimentator bist, kennst und liebst du bereits diese Art von Lösungen. Eine Heuristik ist jeder Ansatz zur Lösung eines
Problems, der pragmatisch, aber nicht unbedingt optimal ist. Das ist großartig, denn Lösungen müssen nicht unbedingt
optimal sein, um sehr nützlich zu sein. Denk zum Beispiel an eine Finanzanwendung. Wir haben noch keine
exponentielle Beschleunigung für die meisten Finanzalgorithmen gefunden, die Quantum nutzen könnte. Aber das spielt nicht unbedingt eine Rolle. Wir brauchen keine optimale Lösung
im Finanzbereich, zumindest nicht, weil eine Lösung, die nur 1 % effizienter ist, Milliarden von Dollar
Gewinn bedeuten könnte. Wie wissen wir also, welche Anwendungsfälle und Probleme gerade jetzt für Quantum Computing geeignet sein könnten? Und damit meine ich,
dass es erhebliche Gründe gibt zu glauben, dass Quantum Utility oder sogar Quantum Advantage jetzt oder
in naher Zukunft gefunden werden könnte. Vielleicht ist es einfacher, zunächst Dinge zu nennen, die das Problem definitiv nicht haben sollte. Es
darf keine riesige Anzahl von qubits erfordern. Wir haben noch keine Prozessoren mit Tausenden bis Millionen von verfügbaren qubits – das ist einer der Hauptgründe,
warum Shors Algorithmus und ähnliche noch so weit entfernt sind. Die circuits können auch nicht unglaublich tief sein. Es fällt mir wirklich schwer,
euch genau zu sagen, welche circuit-Tiefe nicht funktioniert, da das von so vielen Faktoren abhängt. Aber generell gilt: Wenn euer
Experiment eine Tiefe erfordert, die ihr in der Literatur noch nicht erreicht gesehen habt, könnte es schwierig werden. Und
schließlich kann jede Art von Algorithmus, von dem wir wissen, dass er Fehlerkorrektur erfordern wird, noch nicht ausgeführt werden. Was wir jedoch suchen sollten, sind Experimente, die
die meisten der auf einer gegebenen QPU verfügbaren qubits nutzen. Wir haben auch die
Bedeutung von Fehlerminderung und -unterdrückung betont, und schließlich sollte es eine offensichtliche Erweiterung zu zukünftigen
Anwendungen geben, die für die Gesellschaft wichtig wären und die wir irgendwann zu Quantum
Advantage führen sehen könnten. Sprechen wir jetzt über einige Beispiele von Anwendungsfällen, die in drei Hauptkategorien fallen, die wir
als am wahrscheinlichsten für günstige Ergebnisse in naher bis mittlerer
Zukunft identifiziert haben. Der erste Bereich ist die Simulation der Natur. Darüber haben wir bereits gesprochen. Es gibt
so viele Möglichkeiten für Quantencomputer, die Forschung auf molekularer und atomarer Ebene zu verbessern.
Der Grund dafür ist, dass aktuelle klassische Methoden durch fundamental ineffiziente mathematische
Beschreibungen von Atomstrukturen begrenzt sind. Das Speichern und Manipulieren eines Quantum-Zustands erfordert exponentiell viele Ressourcen
auf einem klassischen Computer, aber effizient auf einem Quantencomputer durchgeführt werden kann, und das macht die Materialsimulation
und chemische Modellierung zu einigen der vielversprechendsten Anwendungsbereiche. Genauer gesagt könnte dies zu
Entwicklungen bei der Kohlendioxidabscheidung, alternativen Batterien oder der Erfindung neuer Medikamente führen. Einige
Algorithmen, die in diesem Bereich besonders relevant sind, sind der Variational Quantum Eigensolver VQE, der verwendet wird, um
bestimmte Eigenschaften eines Materials zu schätzen, wie z. B. Gleichgewichts- oder Minimalenergiezustände. Ein weiteres Beispiel ist der
zeitdynamische Simulationsalgorithmus TDS, der verwendet wird, um Antwortfunktionen oder spektrale Eigenschaften von
Materialien zu schätzen. Ich wollte auch einen Neuling erwähnen: die stichprobenbasierte Quantendiagonalisierung, von der wir glauben, dass wir
in naher Zukunft noch viel mehr hören werden. Der nächste Anwendungsbereich ist Optimierung. Optimierung ist nun wirklich
allgegenwärtig in der Informatik, wie du dir vorstellen kannst, sodass die Anwendungsfälle recht zahlreich und vielfältig sind.
Einige Beispiele, von denen wir aber oft hören, sind Portfoliooptimierung im Finanzwesen, Industriedesign und auch
Verteilung und Lieferkette. Der häufigste Algorithmus, den du wahrscheinlich im Zusammenhang mit Optimierung hören wirst, ist der, den wir
bereits eingehend behandelt haben: der Quantum Approximate Optimization Algorithm oder
QAOA. Schließlich ist ein Bereich, für den es in den letzten Jahren viel Begeisterung gab, das Quantenmaschinelle Lernen. Ich
denke, es ist fair zu sagen, dass QML wahrscheinlich nicht so bald wie die Simulation eintreten wird, aber dennoch gibt es
einige beeindruckende Algorithmen, an denen Menschen kontinuierlich arbeiten und die einigen sehr wichtigen Anwendungsfällen entsprechen.
Einige dieser möglichen Anwendungsfälle sind die Verarbeitung natürlicher Sprache, die Analyse des Netzwerkverkehrs und sogar Betrug
Erkennung bei Finanztransaktionen. Relevante Algorithmen in diesem Bereich sind die Quantum Support Vector
Machine, Quantumneuronale Netze und Quantum Generative Adversarial Networks. Zur Klarstellung: Diese drei
Gruppen, die wir gerade beschrieben haben, sind breite Anwendungsbereiche. Es ist auch erwähnenswert, dass es in der Community
auch einen Nutzen für Gruppen gibt, die zusammenarbeiten und sich auf ein bestimmtes Thema konzentrieren. IBM hat vor nicht allzu langer Zeit eine Initiative ins Leben gerufen,
die sogenannten Working Groups, um Mitarbeitern zu helfen, sich zu treffen und in vier spezifischen Bereichen produktive Synergien zu schaffen.
Bereiche sind: Gesundheitswesen und Biowissenschaften, Materialien und HPC, Hochenergiephysik und
Optimierung. Hier sind unsere aktuellen Gruppen und die daran beteiligten Einrichtungen. Wenn du mehr darüber erfahren möchtest,
was die Working Groups tun, haben wir vier ihrer Whitepaper in der Beschreibung unten beigefügt. Wie gesagt,
denke ich, dass das Beste, was man an diesem Punkt des Kurses tun kann, darin besteht, einige Zeit damit zu verbringen, zu erkunden, an welchen Problemen die Leute an der Spitze
dieser Technologie arbeiten, und unser Gespür dafür zu entwickeln, welche Arten von Algorithmen funktionieren werden und wie
man sie anwendet. Und bevor wir beginnen, möchte ich klarstellen, dass das Hauptziel hier nicht darin besteht, jeden
Detail der Experimente zu verstehen. Diese Art von Analyse kann selbst für Experten sehr einschüchternd sein, wenn das Paper leicht
außerhalb deines Fachgebiets liegt. Das Ziel ist einfach, ein Gespür für die Art von Problemen zu entwickeln, für die Quantum-
computer geeignet sind und wie man mit ihnen umgeht. Und wenn du an den feineren Details interessiert bist und das einige
eigene Ideen bei dir geweckt hat, ermutige ich dich auf jeden Fall, die vollständigen Paper selbst zu lesen. Die spezifischen Anwendungsfälle und
Paper, die wir eingehend betrachten werden, sind diese: Zuerst werden wir ein Paper erkunden, das die
Simulation der Hadrondynamik behandelt. Dies fällt in die Kategorie Hochenergiephysik. Als nächstes werden wir uns ein Optimierungsproblem ansehen,
nämlich bias field counter-adiabatic Quantum Optimization, und schließlich werden wir uns ein weiteres
Simulationsproblem ansehen, diesmal jedoch mit Fokus auf mRNA, einem entscheidenden Molekül für die
Medikamenten- und Therapieentwicklung. Ob du mit diesen Papern vertraut bist oder nicht – kein Problem, wir werden
alle drei durchgehen. Es sind wichtige Paper, die Probleme von beträchtlicher Größe angehen und zeigen, wie Quantum-
computer beginnen, als weitere Methode der wissenschaftlichen Forschung eingesetzt zu werden. Als Erstes steht die Simulation der Hadrondynamik
an, und wir werden in ein Paper von Martin Savages Gruppe an der Universität Washington eintauchen, das den Titel „Quantum
Simulations of Hadron Dynamics in the Schwinger Model Using 112
qubits" trägt. Wenn du kein Hochenergiephysiker bist, bist du möglicherweise dennoch mit dem Begriff Hadron vertraut, wie z. B. im
Large Hadron Collider oder LHC, dem riesigen Teilchenbeschleuniger mit einem Umfang von 27 Kilometern, der es
ermöglichte, das Higgs-Boson schließlich zu beobachten. Ein Hadron ist nun ein subatomares zusammengesetztes Teilchen, das aus anderen kleinen
Teilchen namens Quarks besteht. Einige Beispiele wären Neutronen und Protonen. Zur Einordnung: Der LHC wurde gebaut,
um die Erforschung der grundlegenden Physik zu ermöglichen und zu untersuchen, was mit Teilchen passiert, wenn sie mit extrem hoher Energie kollidieren.
In dieser kreisförmigen Röhre hoffen Wissenschaftler durch diese Methode, mehr darüber zu erfahren, wie das frühe Universum entstanden ist.
Und wie ich bereits sagte, wurde es auch verwendet, um das Boson zu finden, ein schwer fassbares Teilchen, das für die Masse
fundamentaler Teilchen verantwortlich ist. Im Prinzip könnten die Wechselwirkungen dieser Teilchen
von Anfang bis Ende mit einem ausreichend leistungsstarken Quantencomputer simuliert werden. Wir sind noch nicht ganz so weit, aber es werden Fortschritte erzielt.
Das Schwinger-Modell ist ein einfaches Modell, das verwendet wird, um einige dieser Dynamiken zu simulieren, und hat sich zu einem der
beliebtesten Modelle entwickelt. Die Details des Modells sind im Moment nicht so wichtig, aber für die
Neugierigen: Es ist ein Modell, das das Verhalten von Elektronen und Positronen beschreibt, die über Photonen in 1+1-D-
Dimensionen wechselwirken, d. h. es gibt eine räumliche Dimension und die Zeit. Das Modell weist viele Ähnlichkeiten mit der Quanten-
chromodynamik auf, die beschreibt, wie Quarks und Hadronen wechselwirken. Das ist extrem schwer zu simulieren, daher wird das
Schwinger-Modell oft als Spielzeugmodell verwendet, um einige Phänomene zu untersuchen, die tatsächlich für
beide gemeinsam sind. Die Art und Weise, wie wir mit diesem Beispiel und den anderen Beispielen vorgehen, die ich hier ausgewählt habe, ist
die, indem wir uns eine Reihe von Fragen stellen. Die erste ist: Warum hatten wir Grund zu der Annahme, dass die Simulation davon
auf einem Quantencomputer überhaupt funktionieren würde? In diesem Fall haben die Elektronen und Positronen im Schwinger-Modell einen Abschirmungseffekt,
der dazu führt, dass Korrelationen zwischen entfernten Fons exponentiell mit der Separation abnehmen. Das bedeutet, dass es
nicht so viele Weitbereichswechselwirkungen von einem qubit auf einer Seite des Chips zu einem anderen auf der anderen Seite des Chips gibt,
was wir wissen, ist sehr fehleranfällig. Das ist also wirklich gut für die Hardware, die uns heute zur Verfügung steht. Als nächstes ist
dieses Thema überhaupt von Interesse? Nun, ich habe euch eigentlich schon ein wenig davon überzeugt, dass ja, Hochenergiephysik von großem
Interesse ist. Die Leute waren bereit, Milliarden von Dollar auszugeben, um den LHC zu bauen, und Tausende von Wissenschaftlern und
Techniker auf der ganzen Welt haben ihr Leben diesem Bereich gewidmet – so wichtig ist er – aber das
Schwinger-Modell ist vereinfacht und nicht dafür konzipiert, drei räumliche Dimensionen abzudecken; dennoch ist es ein
wichtiges Modell, da es derzeit testbare Ausschnitte und nützliche Vereinfachungen einer vollständigen
Theorie liefert. Zuletzt: Wie wurde diese Arbeit durchgeführt, oder welchen Ansatz würde man verwenden, wenn man die Arbeit in
Simulationsexperimenten fortsetzen wollte? VQE ist einer der häufigsten Ansätze, und der erste Schritt ist fast immer derselbe:
den Grundzustand vorbereiten – in diesem Fall ist es ein Vakuumzustand – und in diesem Experiment verwenden sie eine neue Version von VQE namens SC
adapt VQE, um sowohl den Grundzustand als auch das Hadron-Wellenpaket auf dem Vakuum vorzubereiten. Der nächste Schritt ist dann,
die Hadronen zu entwickeln oder in der Zeit zu propagieren. Zuletzt müssen wir die
Observablen identifizieren, die wir detektieren wollen. Wenn dir diese Schritte irgendwie bekannt vorkommen – abzüglich des Hadron-Wellen-
pakets – dann liegt das daran, dass diese Schritte dem, was wir im QAOA-Beispiel der vorherigen Episode behandelt haben, sehr ähnlich sind.
Hoffentlich erkennst du hier langsam Muster: Die Komponenten, die für VQE benötigt werden, sind QAOA sehr ähnlich.
Wir starten in einem bekannten Zustand – hier dem Vakuumzustand – und lassen ihn dann mit einer Reihe von exponenzierten
Hamiltonians in handhabbare Abschnitte unterteilt in der Zeit entwickeln, wobei n die Anzahl der Unterteilungen ist. Der einzige große Unterschied hier
ist, dass wir das Wellenpaket des Hadrons zentriert in unserem circuit erstellen, bevor wir es entwickeln lassen. Wie wird das also
gemacht? Nun, der Vakuumzustand ist der Grundzustand, und wir haben bereits grob behandelt, wie man diesen abbildet. Nun ist die Vorbereitung des Hadron-
Wellenpakets etwas anders: Auf diesem Vakuum kann ein Hadron angeregt werden, indem man ein Fermion-Antifermion-Paar auf
benachbarten Gitterplätzen erzeugt. Durch das Vorbereiten einer Superposition solcher Hadronen an verschiedenen Positionen kann ein beliebiges Wellen-
paket vorbereitet werden. Die Autoren zentrierten ihr Wellenpaket in der Mitte des circuit, um die Entwicklung zu beobachten,
ohne eine Grenze zu überschreiten. Aber denk daran: Das Wichtigste beim Arbeiten mit verrauschten QPUs ist, die
circuit-Tiefe handhabbar zu halten. Dafür nutzt das SC adapt VQE-Protokoll Symmetrie und
Hierarchien in Längenskalen, um flache Quantum-circuits für die Zustandsvorbereitung zu bestimmen. Die Idee ist, dass dies
einen Ansatz mit einer kleineren Anzahl von Parametern erzeugt, was einer geringeren Tiefe entspricht. Weitere Details findest du natürlich
im Paper, als wir hier Zeit haben, also schau es dir unbedingt an. Schauen wir uns jetzt die Ergebnisse an: Dieses Experiment wurde auf
einem IBM Quantum Heron-Gerät durchgeführt und implementierte einige verschiedene Arten von Fehlerminderung und -unterdrückung,
darunter eine neuere Technik namens Operator-Dekohärenz-Renormierung sowie dynamisches Entkoppeln, Zero-Noise-
Extrapolation und Pauli-Twirling. Versuchen wir nun, die Daten zu interpretieren. Die Observable, die wir tatsächlich
messen werden, um zu beobachten, wie sich das Wellenpaket ausbreitet, wird chirales Kondensat genannt – das ist etwas
abstrakt, aber es ist im Grunde eine superfluide Phase der Hadronen. Wir können das Wellenpaket hier zentriert auf den
Gitterplätzen sehen, die für dieses Experiment vorgesehen sind, wobei die Farbe dem chiralen Kondensat entspricht. Die
linke Seite zeigt die fehlerfreien Ergebnisse des Simulators, während die rechte Seite die Ergebnisse des IBM Quantum-
Computers Torino zeigt. Idealerweise wären diese wegen der Symmetrie Spiegelbilder voneinander, du kannst also sehen, dass es einige
Unvollkommenheiten gibt. Diese vertikale y-Achse entspricht den Zeitabschnitten, die ich
zuvor gemessen habe. Warum machen wir also keine horizontalen Schnitte durch den ersten und letzten Zeitschritt der Daten, um zu sehen,
was mit dem Wellenpaket zum Zeitpunkt tau gleich 1 passiert – hier in Orange entsprechend
diesem Schnitt? Du kannst sehen, dass das chirale Kondensat schmal und lokalisiert ist. Es stimmt auch sehr gut mit der
Simulation überein, die zum Vergleich durchgeführt wurde. Bei tau gleich 14 ist es jedoch viel weiter ausgebreitet und weniger
lokalisiert – vielleicht ist der Vergleich mit dem Simulator jetzt nicht ganz so perfekt, aber du kannst trotzdem offensichtlich eine sehr gute Übereinstimmung zwischen Theorie und Daten sehen.
Das ist ermutigend. Zusammenfassend ist dies ein sehr cooles Beispiel für die Art von Simulationsarbeit, an die du vielleicht zunächst nicht denkst,
wenn du Quantencomputer einsetzen willst – aber tatsächlich kannst du es, und es funktioniert. Es ist nicht perfekt, aber du musst kein
Teilchenphysikexperte sein, um zu sehen, dass der Quantencomputer die nach außen gerichtete Propagation des Wellenpakets genau vorhersagt,
was genau das ist, was wir zu finden erwarten würden. Hoffentlich wird die zukünftige Arbeit in diesem Bereich fortgesetzt, und Hochenergiephysiker
werden weiterhin Wege finden, Quantum Computing in ihre Arbeitsabläufe zu integrieren. Das Ziel ist es, theoretische Probleme präziser zu lösen,
also solche, die klassisch nicht lösbar sind, und Experimente zu nutzen, um Theorien zu akzeptieren oder zu verwerfen, in der Hoffnung, neue
Physik zu entdecken, verbesserte Detektoren zu bauen und zu einem besseren Verständnis der Natur auf ihrer fundamentalsten
Ebene zu gelangen. Unser nächstes Beispiel konzentriert sich auf Optimierung und wird ein tiefer Einblick in ein Paper namens „Biased Field
Digitized Counter Adiabatic Quantum Optimization" sein, das von Mitgliedern des Kipu Quantum-Teams an der
Universität des Baskenlandes in Spanien durchgeführt wurde. Wir beginnen wie zuvor
mit einer Reihe von Definitionen. Die erste ist „counter adiabatic" – das ist eine Art von Entwicklung, die nicht-adiabatische
Effekte unterdrückt, die ein System erfährt, unabhängig davon, wie schnell diese Prozesse ablaufen. Erinnere dich an das adiabatische Theorem aus der
letzten Episode: Man muss ein System normalerweise sehr langsam entwickeln lassen, wenn es im Grundzustand bleiben soll.
Das ist ein großes Problem, weil je langsamer wir die Dinge entwickeln lassen müssen, desto mehr Zeit haben wir für Fehler,
die auftreten können. Counter Adiabatic Driving, oft als CD abgekürzt, zielt darauf ab, dem entgegenzuwirken, indem
Terme hinzugefügt werden, die diesen unerwünschten Anregungen entgegenwirken. Die Hauptidee hier ist es, das gesamte Experiment zu beschleunigen und
die Quantum-circuit-Tiefe zu reduzieren, indem Anregungen unterdrückt werden, die zu unerwünschten
Übergängen führen könnten. Sprechen wir nun darüber, was ein Bias-Feld ist. Andere iterative Algorithmen wie VQE nehmen klassische Parameter in
diese Zustände auf und verwenden klassische Optimierer, um den mehrdimensionalen Parameterraum nach dem Satz
zu durchsuchen, der einen minimalen Erwartungswert für einen festen Hamiltonian liefert. In diesem Fall variieren sie stattdessen den Hamiltonian bei jedem
Schritt und bewegen sich adiabatisch von einem bekannten Fall zum interessierenden Fall. Da es aber keine klassischen Parameter gibt, die übergeben werden,
und keine variationelle Wellenfunktion: Wie aktualisiert man seinen Zustand von einem Durchlauf des Hamiltonians zum nächsten? Nun,
sie fügen dem Hamiltonian ein Bias-Feld hinzu: Was auch immer der niedrigste Energiezustand aus dem vorherigen Lauf war, sie fügen einen Term in den
Hamiltonian ein, um den Zustand zu dessen Gunsten zu beeinflussen. Warum ist dieses Experiment also von
Interesse? Erstens ist dies ein neuer Ansatz, der allgemeiner auf andere Optimierungsprobleme angewendet werden könnte,
aber in diesem Fall haben sie ihn auf ein Ising-Spinglas-Problem angewendet. Wie wir zuvor besprochen haben, können viele kombinatorische
Optimierungsprobleme als das Lösen nach Niedrigenergie-Zuständen von Ising-Hamiltonians umformuliert werden. Das Ising-
Das Modell ist eine Reihe von mikroskopischen Spins, die auf einem Array verteilt sind. Das Modell kann verwendet werden, um ein Spin-Glas zu beschreiben, in dem
die Magnetisierung ungeordnet ist – die kleinen magnetischen Momente sind grundsätzlich zufällig im Array ausgerichtet, und
warum dachten wir, dass das gut funktionieren würde? Wir haben bereits ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, wie wir zwei typische Probleme bekämpfen, die bei
Variationsalgorithmen auftreten, als wir die Definitionen des Papers behandelt haben. Um den Algorithmus zusammenzufassen, den sie
vorschlagen: Er beschleunigt die Evolution, um die circuit-Tiefe zu reduzieren, und unterdrückt gleichzeitig nicht-adiabatische Übergänge.
Außerdem verlässt er sich nicht auf klassische Optimierungsroutinen, was ein Problem sein kann, das zu Barren
Plateaus und zum Feststecken in lokalen Minima führt. Schließlich stellen die Autoren auch sicher, die Wechselwirkungen im Problem-
Hamiltonoperator mit der Hardware-Konnektivität im realen QPU auszurichten, was immer sehr wichtig ist. Wie funktioniert das also?
Wie gesagt, es werden hier keine klassischen Optimierer verwendet, wie es bei iterativen Quantenalgorithmen oft der Fall ist.
Stattdessen verfeinert der Bias-Field-Digitized
Quantum-Optimierungsalgorithmus, indem er die Lösung jeder Iteration als Eingabe für die nächste einspeist, schrittweise den Grundzustand und bringt ihn immer näher an den
endgültig entwickelten Zustand heran. In Kombination mit kontra-adiabatischen Protokollen können wir das sogar mit kurzen Quanten-
circuits erreichen, die auf verrauschter Hardware reibungslos laufen sollten. Als das Experiment durchgeführt wurde, entschieden sich die Autoren,
den Algorithmus auf dem 127-qubit IBM Quantum Computer Brisbane auszuführen. Die Autoren zeigten hier
die Eth-isierung des Optimierungsalgorithmus für eine nächste-Nachbar-zufällig-generierte Spin-Glas-Instanz
mit über 100 qubits. Sie vergleichen ideale Simulationsergebnisse von DCQ und BF-DCQ
sowie das experimentelle Ergebnis, und sie zeigen auch ein Ergebnis eines klassischen Lösers namens Goobi als Referenz.
Mit nur 10 Iterationen liefert BF-DCQ eine drastische Verbesserung im Vergleich zu
DCQ. Obwohl das experimentelle Ergebnis aufgrund von Rauschen etwas vom idealen Ergebnis abweicht, ist die Leistung dennoch
besser als das ideale DCQ. Das zeigt, dass bei der
Quantenoptimierung noch immer großartige Fortschritte erzielt werden und gute Ergebnisse mit über 100 qubits gemeldet werden – zum ersten Mal
überhaupt. Zu guter Letzt gibt es ein sehr interessantes Paper zur mRNA-Strukturvorhersage von unseren Freunden bei
Madna Pharmaceuticals. Es heißt: mRNA-Sekundärstrukturvorhersage mit quantencomputern im Utility-Maßstab.
Zunächst: Falls du, wie ich, schon einige Jahre keinen Biologiekurs mehr besucht hast, kannst du dich auffrischen, was
mRNA ist. Messenger-RNA ist eine Art von RNA, die an der Proteinsynthese beteiligt ist.
Sie liest grundsätzlich Anweisungen, die von der DNA gegeben werden. Die Sekundärstruktur von mRNA ist mehr oder weniger die Art, wie die Kette gefaltet ist, und
das RNA-Sekundärstrukturvorhersage-Problem ist das Problem, die stabilste Faltung der Sequenz zu finden.
der Basen von Nukleotiden, aus denen DNA und RNA bestehen – das wären C, G, U und A.
Dieses Bild hier zeigt einige der häufig in mRNA vorkommenden Faltungsstrukturen. Jede Farbe hebt eine
andere Sekundärstruktur hervor. Die genauen Eigenschaften, die eine dieser Strukturen gegenüber einer
anderen bevorzugter machen, sind nicht gut verstanden. Alles, was wir tun können, ist herauszufinden, welche die niedrigste freie Energie im Vergleich zum
ungefalteten Zustand hat – und genau da kommen Quantencomputer ins Spiel. Warum sind mRNA-Sekundärstrukturen also
wichtig? Nun, ihre genaue Vorhersage ist tatsächlich entscheidend, und zwar nicht nur für das Verständnis von DNA und unseren Genen, sondern auch
für das Design von RNA-basierten Therapeutika wie dem Covid-19-Impfstoff. Es gibt Grund zu der Annahme, dass der Ansatz in
diesem Paper funktionieren würde, weil dies seit langem als ein anspruchsvolles Optimierungsproblem für klassische
Computer gilt, aufgrund der riesigen Anzahl möglicher Konfigurationen. Und für einige Konfigurationen ist es tatsächlich bekannt, dass es sich um ein
NP-vollständiges Problem handelt. Auf einem Quantencomputer können wir die Sekundärstrukturvorhersage jedoch als ein
binäres Optimierungsproblem formulieren – etwas, das wir zu handhaben wissen. Außerdem gibt es in der Literatur bereits Belege
für genaue RNA-Vorhersagen auf kleinen Quantengeräten und Quantensimulatoren. Die naheliegende Frage ist also:
Würde das auf größerer Hardware funktionieren? Das Experiment wird mithilfe von etwas namens dem Conditional Value
at Risk Variational Quantum Eigensolver durchgeführt, einer Modifikation des traditionellen VQE-Algorithmus, die
eine bessere Konvergenz erzielen soll. Dieser Plot zeigt die Verteilung der Messwahr-
scheinlichkeiten der Stichproben-Bitstrings mit den entsprechenden Energien für 42
Nukleotide, eine 80-qubit-Instanz. Hier symbolisieren die Bitstrings Paarungen der
Nukleotide. Es zeigt, dass der Bitstring mit der niedrigsten Energie einen Energiewert von -140 hat, was dem niedrigsten
Energie-Bitstring entspricht, der vom vergleichenden klassischen Löser gefunden wurde. Das ist großartig, und das ist die optimal gefaltete
Struktur jener Nukleotidkette, basierend auf dem Bitstring mit der niedrigsten Energie, den die Hardware
gefunden hat. Damit haben wir das Ende dieser Episode erreicht. Mein Ziel war es hier nicht, dich mit
Details aus verschiedenen Forschungsarbeiten zu überwältigen. Wie gesagt, ich wollte dir einfach genug Kontext geben, um zu verstehen, wie
Cutting-Edge-Arbeit auf dem Gebiet gerade aussieht. Die Hoffnung ist, dass das einige Zahnräder bei
allen in Gang setzt, und dass du durch das Sehen, wie andere Probleme angehen, Verbindungen herstellen und das
Selbstvertrauen gewinnen wirst, neue Quantenexperimente zu wagen, die du vielleicht vorher nicht gewagt hättest. Und vielleicht werden einige davon nicht
aufgehen – das ist in Ordnung, das ist der Sinn von Forschung. Denke daran, dass die Arten von Problemen, an denen wir
interessiert sind, entweder nach Methodik oder nach Thema gruppiert werden können, und wir haben die aufgeführt, die wir für
die vielversprechendsten auf kurze Sicht halten. Denke daran: Quantum Computing ist nicht für alles gut, und das ist wirklich nur ein
Beweis dafür, wie gut wir im klassischen Computing geworden sind. Nur weil du denkst, du könntest Quantum Computing
auf ein Problem anwenden, bedeutet das leider nicht, dass es interessante Ergebnisse liefern wird. Du musst die Skalierung und die circuit-
Tiefe berücksichtigen – sie ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert. Wir brauchen sie groß genug, um interessante Arbeit zu leisten, die klassische
Computer nicht können. Aber im Moment, wegen des Hardware-Rauschens, können wir sie nicht auf riesige Größen treiben, weil die Fidelity
sinken wird. Es geht darum, den richtigen Mittelweg zu finden und zu wissen, dass es ein sich bewegendes Ziel ist. Nimm dir also etwas Zeit
zwischen jetzt und der nächsten Episode, um wirklich über einige Probleme nachzudenken, auf die du gestoßen bist, und wie du sie mit dem angehen möchtest, was wir gelernt haben.
Bis zu diesem Punkt: Sei kreativ und setze dir keine Grenzen. Und wenn du Ideen hast, auch wenn du denkst, sie sind ein
bisschen verrückt – lass es mich in den Kommentaren unten wissen. Danke fürs Zuschauen, und bis zum nächsten Mal!